[Music]
hello everyone
we are going to continue with our
discussion of problems and
in this lecture we are going to consider
a slightly different kind of problem
so instead of straight beams which we
have been considering till now
we are going to consider this kind of a
curved beam but please note that
this is a curved beam
under the restriction that it is
quite thin what i mean by
thin is that if you consider this
dimension
uh if you consider
this dimension this is the thickness
that thickness
are sometimes that is also referred to
as the depth of the beam
if uh what we have here is uh
suppose this is the center of our uh of
our circle
so so this is this is a curved beam uh
in the form of a semicircle so what i'm
saying is that
suppose our
the radius of our circle is capital r
then this can be considered to be a
thin curved beam provided
r is greater than
twice the depth
okay so this is our depth
so r is greater if r is greater than
twice the depth what we say is that our
beam is thin
okay the question here is
what is the deflection
the nature of the question is quite the
same as what we have been dealing with
now
until now so what is the deflection at
the point of application of
this point p or or the
or the of this point force p okay so
deflection
and we are interested in both the
vertical
and horizontal deflection
and the point of application of the
force p
first considering the vertical
deflection
this is a straightforward application of
the castigliano's theorem on deflection
however for the horizontal deflection
you note
that we do not really have a force at
this point
which is directed along the horizontal
direction so in that for that horizontal
deflection we have to consider a
fictitious force
but we'll come to that later first of
all the straightforward case of the
vertical deflection
and we'll see what a special measure we
have to take
uh considering that this beam
is indeed in the form of a semicircle
okay so
the the procedure is quite the same
actually in fact nothing changes
so for the vertical deflection
what we do as before is to take a cut
section
okay so suppose we take a cut section
here
now if you consider the
the free body diagram of
the of the section of the beam which is
to the right of this
cut section so now it is going to look
like this
a slightly rough diagram here
it's going to look like this and
[Music]
you understand that because over this
part there is no externally applied load
so even if you considered this kind of a
moment
and shear force both of those values are
going to be zero okay
so had there been some load at this end
or somewhere else
on this portion of the beam then
certainly we could have non-zero values
of this
bending moment and shear force but you
do not have those things
so it is as if the part of the of this
beam
from this push from this point up to
this point
it is kind of inert uh from the point of
view of the load
okay it does not mean that it does not
deflect of course it deflects
you understand that when this thing is
pointing i mean acting downward on it
the whole
beam will move slightly downward as a
result all the material points which
constitute this
portion of the beam they will also
deflect downward
and rightward but in terms
of the of the internal resistances that
show up
they are inert okay so what do we do
so we consider a cut section here
so that instead of this kind of a
instead of this kind of a free body
diagram
which doesn't really give us much
we instead have
we instead have this portion of the beam
now
as a result of this cut
now of course the
externally applied load will be very
much appearing here
and the bending moment
sorry about that the bending moment
is here the shear force is here and
again i
urge all of you to please
make a note of why the
default positive sense of this moment
and shear force are directed in the way
that i have drawn here
this has to do with the choice of our
coordinate system and the coordinate
system that we are indeed choosing
is this r theta system
so
this is our r and this
is our theta okay measured from this
horizontal
so you think for a moment about the
positivity of this
or the positivity positivity convention
of this shear force and the positivity
convention
of this bending moment and convince
yourself that
uh so
uh convince yourself that this is indeed
the correct thing so let me also check
this
so r uh if you consider the theta to
have rotated
all the way here this r is going to come
here and this is going to be
directed in this sense so that is very
much uh
the correct sense of the shear force
regarding the
m this m basically comes about as a
result
of the sigma theta theta
which will be directed in this fashion
and i think i have to make this
reverse
sorry about that so you understand that
this
heart is in this sense and the sigma
theta theta is in this sense
so let me just draw that
my sigma theta theta will be in this
sense
which means that if i take
the moment arm to be r it is going to
curl downward
which means that the sense that i have
drawn here for the
m and that has to be changed
this is this is my
m now what is the expression for this
m you see
the m here is going to be balanced by
the contribution to the moment
which is imparted by this force e
the moment for this force p will be
calculated about an axis which is
passing
through this end and for that the moment
arm you note
is going to be this portion
this is the moment arm for that so this
distance that is going to be the moment
arm
and what is that so
you understand that this particular
angle
okay so if this entire thing is theta
let me clarify that diagram
if this entire angle is theta
then this particular thing is theta
minus pi
by 2 and uh
and this this radius of course is
capital r so
this distance is going to be r times
sine theta minus pi by 2 let me write
that down
so force and the moment
arm that is r sine theta minus pi by 2
and the sense of it is
is opposite to this bending moment
m
this m is in the anti-clockwise sense
and the contribution
from on to the moment from this force p
is will be in the
clockwise sense this is
this is minus now we have to be very
careful
uh in incorporating the heavy side or
the
step function because
as we have just discussed uh this
portion from theta equal to 0 to pi by 2
that is not going to contribute anything
to the moment
so this is our expression for m
so all that we have to do for for
finding out
the vertical deflection i write d with a
subscript v to denote the vertical
deflection
that will be equal to
integration 0 to pi
[Music]
uh and
even before i write this it'd be a
little bit more systematic
what i'm doing here is
del u del p and
the u as before the strain energy
that is very much m square by twice e
i
earlier for the straight beams in this
portion
i used to write this as dx and i used to
carry out the integration
from 0 to capital l which was the entire
length of the beam
now the entire length of the beam is
given by this
r times pi okay so the elemental
uh portion of that while traversing in
this theta direction
will be r d theta and we are going to
carry out the integration from 0 to pi
so overall what we are going to have is
this
0 to pi m
by e i
del m del p
r d theta so the rest of it is just
carrying out the integration steps so
i'll not do it here
instead i just note down the answer here
which is
pi p r cube by four e i
okay now now the next thing that we are
going to try
is uh the horizontal deflection okay
so
i'll just copy this
figure
go to the next page
now everything remains the same as
before
but now what i want to do is uh
include here a fictitious force
a fictitious force q in the horizontal
direction
and now as a result of this what is my m
so this m is still like this the
contribution to the
m due to m due to the p will be exactly
the same as before
so this is p
times r sine
theta minus pi by 2
times every side
theta minus 5 by 2 and again this comes
with this minus sign
now we have to consider the contribution
to the moment
due to this force q this fictitious
force q which will ultimately set equal
to
zero this force q about again about an
axis which is passing through this end
and this time you note
that the moment arm for this force q
is this distance it is this distance
so earlier it was that distance for the
force p
and here about this end
the or from this end the the moment on
is this vertical distance and that
vertical distance
is uh so we
you write q first and then
this is r you please note that this
entire distance is r
and this particular distance okay so
from here
what i am saying is that this distance
this particular distance is going to be
r
cos theta minus pi by 2
so it is going to be
and again it comes multiplied
or it should be multiplied with this
heavy side
of theta minus pi by 2
so this entire thing
okay and you please note that again the
sense
of the moment due to this q is in the
clockwise
direction about this axis passing
through this end
so it should be again with this minus
this entire thing is equal to
zero so just like before what we have to
do
is for the for the horizontal deflection
so dh the h subscript stands for the
horizontal deflection
which should be del u del q but
evaluated at q equal to zero
so this is
again as before we carry out the
integration from 0 to pi to
cover the entire length of the beam and
just like before
we have
we have to be very careful in noting
that this entire calculation has to be
carried out
at q equal to zero
maybe i should just write this thing
outside
if we actually carry out this
intermediate steps
what we'll finally obtain for the
horizontal deflection is this
p r cube by
twice e i
all right so uh those are the answers
for the horizontal and the vertical
deflection now
we can have various other variations
on this circular problem and then if you
for example you could be asked to find
out
the reaction forces
for a statically indeterminate kind of a
beam structure
involving such a such a curved
curved orientation or curved nature
of the beam up in a fashion similar
to our earlier problem uh where we
considered
a uh structure of where the effect
of not only the bending but also the
torsion came into play
yeah in a similar fashion we can have a
structure where part of it
is just like a curved beam and another
part is maybe straight
so we can have various uh combinations
of the things that we have learned as
part of different problems
okay so it can get very very interesting
so on that note
i will end this lecture thank you very
much